Well today's council meeting was
actually quite a light agenda, it's my
first one back around the table and I've
enjoyed being back.
The Ohoka Gatekeepers Lodge has been moved into
the Ohoka Domain
and that was approved today.
and we also are looking at sending some
Councillors over to cement our sister
city relationship with Enshi which
is a very important part of
our. international relations.
Today the
council acknowledged Neil Falconer, he
received the Queen's Service Medal in the
New Year Honours for services to
communications and broadcasting.
and we also farewelled a very loved colleague Murray Binnie
who's been our Drainage Manager for many years
and also bought an understanding of Tikanga Māori and Te Reo into the council.
He's been a big part of our Waiata
group and in fostering our relationship
with Ngāi Tūāhuriri and he will be very
sorely missed.
From now on our meetings are going to
get a lot busier with LTP coming
up, our ten year plan, and there's
obviously a lot of discussions to be had
and a lot of submissions to come in from
the community.